laurel hubbard an openly trans
female weightlifter failed to complete
any of her three lifts at the women's
87 kilogram olympic weightlifting
competition
she's become the first out trans woman
to compete at the olympics
hubbard met all the requirements set by
the iwf but her participation came with
controversy yep
what i think it should i would love to
see and this
is just an idealistic
thing an idea i'll call it
i wish that it was a trade program
you get one we get one we'll send you
ronnie
you send us no
we don't want elizabeth okay we want
diana
you know you send us jacob we'll take
rhondesha like i feel like that
it would be better if there was a
kind of a commission where you got the
trade
where you got the trade and you had to
go all the way through
and live like say if the man that's
coming over
he was a postman and now he wants to
work
if he switches at the same time as
somebody else to a different gender
that red rover then they got to be in
that person's job
so if you come over you got to do
whatever that
you know that lady was doing if she's an
esthetician now
ronnie is doing nails and feet
you know and sin yum is doing
selling cutco knives or whatever ronnie
was doing i just think i would love to
see
you know red rover red rover send
sharif right over and we will give you
melissa jane
i would love to see that a little bit
more so that you could keep tabs on what
how it's fully working out then you get
the full transition
can you go all the way over can you then
now your uncle is a woman
but can she do the uncle roll does that
make sense rally
it does do you have any trans in your
family
i don't at least
not that i know of right and it's a lot
of hide and go seek out there
you know i thought i've seen somebody
with kind of a long posse before and i
didn't know what it was but
you know you know you know
you're in your 20s and you just hope god
has a bigger plan for you but
anyway man um yeah that's what's going
on out there
i do feel like the wim
the feminine gender is benefiting more
from this because men we're sending over
some decent men
we've sent over uh
the olympian the decathlete kardashian
uh i don't know what that man's name is
you know his name
i don't we sent that man so you got him
now he's woman out you got him but who
are we getting
you know i'd love us if they would send
us somebody
you know send us uh
um oh that lady that played in friday
night lights you know her name
i don't jesus christ man
not you jesus a different guy but
uh never mind i wish that they would
send her over
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one